et sur place pour france 24 à kiev notre
envoyé spécial sylvain rousseau bonjour
sylvain la destruction de ce vaisseau
c'est un coup porté au moral des russes
et a contrario bien sûr les ukrainiens
exulte
oui effectivement pour pour plusieurs
raisons d'abord parce que c'est le
vaisseau amiral de la flotte russe dans
la mer noire c'est donc le vaisseau où
se situe le commandement russe est le
plus gros le plus le plus important et
puis ne serait ce que par son nom le
moskva il porte le nom de la capitale
russe moscou c'est effectivement
symboliquement extrêmement important
alors vous l'avez vous l'avais dit dans
le sujet c'est une guerre de
communication ensuite entre qui a fait
quoi mais finalement peu importe réel
pour le moral des ukrainiens peu importe
que ce soit eux ou non qu'ils aient
abattu ce bateau l'essentiel c'est
qu'ils le croient et bien sûr que qu'il
puisse le croire cela est bien gonfler
leur moral bien sûr que les ukrainiens
s'attache à tout à toutes ces victoires
et puis alors ils stratégiquement la
perte du vaisseau amiral pour les russes
ça ne sera pas une énorme perte parce
que c'était un vieux bateau ce n'est pas
forcément de lui que partaient les
missiles vers vers le sud de l'ukraine
il n'en reste pas moins que eh bien cela
veut dire que la flotte russe désormais
en mer noire va devoir aussi s'occuper
de sa défense et plus seulement de son
attaque on sait également que boris
johnson le premier ministre britannique
a promis aux ukrainiens au gouvernement
et à l'armée ukrainienne de livrer des
missiles justement destinés à abattre ce
type de bateau dans la mer noire on sait
également que le détroit du bosphore est
fermée par les turcs donc les russes ne
peuvent pas renouveler leur flotte dans
la mer noire à moins de construire les
bateaux sur place et si les ukrainiens
se met à battre les bateaux russes les
uns après les autres cela pourrait
effectivement est un tournant dans ce
conflit au moins ne serait ce que pour
la défense de la vie hautement
stratégique du sud de l'ukraine odessa
et est ce que ça peut aussi remobiliser
les troupes du chrétienne sylvain alors
que l'offensive russe se dessine dans
l'est dans le donbass
alors je vous rassure les tropiques
régnier ne sont absolument pas
démobilisés elles sont galvanisés
d'abord par ce qui s'est passé à kiev
c'est à dire quelques semaines un mois
d'occupation russes et puis les russes
ont dû battre en retraite pour re
concentrer leurs efforts vers l'est du
pays vers le dombass et puis il ya ce
qui se passe à mario paul aussi une
erreur de communication incroyable de la
part des russes ça fait trois jours
maintenant que chaque jour ils nous
annoncent que ils vont prendre mario
paul que la ville est tombée mais la
ville n'est toujours pas tombée il y a
toujours des poches de résistance dans
cette ville dans des complexes
industriels ou dans des tunnels et
finalement les on pensait que la prise
de mario paul créerait donnerait un coup
au moral des ukrainiens finalement ça ne
sera pas le cas puisque et bien 7,7 non
chute finalement de mario paul qui
arrivera à quoi qu'il arrive mais pour
l'instant les russes n'ont réussi qu'à
créer qui a créé des héros et qui
deviendront d'ailleurs à terme d'aidé
des martyrs et tout cela est bien
galvanise encore un peu plus les
tropiques régnait ce qui se passe avec
le mot le mot spa va également leur
remonter le moral et puis il y à tous et
tous ces témoignages qui nous
parviennent ici au nord de kiev à bout
de shaab ou rhodia en choeur ces
histoires de ces centaines de cadavres
de civils découvert ses histoires ses
histoires de torture ces histoires de
viols et bien cela crée également
beaucoup de colère presque de la haine
bien sûr chez chez les ukrainiens et
tout ça oui il peut permettre de faire
basculer cette bataille de l'est d'un
côté ou de l'autre sachant que les
troupes russes en face ont déjà subi un
mois de combats dans le nord avant de se
replier sur leurs positions de l'est ce
qu'elles ont subi l'humiliation
également d'une retraite et qu'elles
sont avec elle on sait qu'elles sont
forcément fatigué après plusieurs jours
d'un transport compliqué et forcément
très inconfortable